l'origine du projet à l'express 91,06
c'est la liaison entre saint quentin en
yvelines et massif aujourd'hui c'est la
construction du 3ème maillot
la première liaison a été réalisée entre
saint quentin en yvelines et
magny-les-hameaux la deuxième a été
réalisée entre massy et l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau
aujourd'hui il s'agit de réaliser le
site propre entre le christ de saclay et
l'école polytechnique à palaiseau
un site propre c'est une infrastructure
complète donc une voie qui est dédié
pour les bus accompagné d'une piste
cyclable et de piste pour les
traitements donc pour permettre la
continuité du mode actif de leurs
déplacements en toute sécurité
les avantages pour l'express 81,06 par
rapport aux circuits aujourd'hui épuisé
c'est que cette infrastructure permettra
de traverser les carrefours avec une
priorité aux feux donner aux bus afin de
gagner en fonctionnalités et en
régularité
le projet a été réalisé en concertation
très étroite avec les acteurs locaux
avec la caps avec l'établissement public
paris-saclay pour permettre d'affiner
lés choix et de retenir le parcours qui
se pourra desservir au mieux les futurs
établissements
aujourd'hui les travaux que nous venons
de voir ont débuté en novembre 2013 et
doivent s'achever fin d'année
prochainement fin 2015 pour la mise en
service
ce projet a un coût total de 58 2
millions d'euros près qu'en valeur 2008
il est entièrement financé par l'état la
région et le département de l'essonne
le matériel roulant et l'exploitation
sont eux 100% financé par le stif
et